[Music]
all right welcome to the special Friday
news breaking edition of Hannity now the
Joe Biden bribery money laundering
allegations Scandal uh let me tell you
we begin with a ton of breaking news
from the swamp all day in Washington a
pathetic new sleight of hand from
Biden's clearly weaponized and
politicized doj as evidence of
corruption against Joe Biden grows with
each passing day today earlier the
Attorney General Merrick Garland just
rolled out a new strategy yep to help
Shield the big guy and the entire Biden
family operation but especially Joe
Biden because today he announced the
appointment of a special counsel to
investigate possible Hunter Biden crimes
but of course he made no mention of
President Joe Biden instead of
appointing someone from outside of the
government to lead this investigation as
by law by the way is recommended under
regulation 28 CFR
600.3 thanks to Greg Jarrett Merrick
Garland waved his magic wand and he just
promoted David Weiss that is the same
Federal prosecutor the one who's been
slow walking the criminal probe into
Hunter Biden for several years he's the
guy that allowed the statute of
limitations to expire on multiple major
felonies before of course then trying to
put together that sweetheart you know a
little deal with Hunter no jail time and
tie it up with a neat little bow and you
know cover it all up a sweetheart deal
that no one else would get that of
course rejected by the federal judge who
thankfully in Delaware actually read the
fine print in this it was a complete get
out of jail free card a blatant attempt
to sweep all Biden allegations Joe and
Hunter under the rug without ever
implicating the big guy or forcing his
beloved Son to go to jail Weiss was
gifting Hunter a deal that involved two
misdemeanor tax filings relations by the
way his office had recommended felonies
and of course the Deferred gun charge
that his own office had been saying yeah
no and an exchange buried deep on page
15 Hunter got a get out of jail free
card a sweeping immunity deal for a
variety of tax uh violations and Drug
crimes and basically every crime
possible in this time period could never
be charged ever again and then the judge
said uh did you mean to put this in
there oh no he didn't your honor and
then wait the defense says wait a minute
that's what we agree we all agreed to so
let me be very clear David Weiss is not
to be trusted this is a sham from from
the get-go but don't take my word for it
two career IRS investigators they were
so appalled at the highly unusual way
that Weiss conducted the entire
investigation that sacred they
sacrificed their own privacy and careers
to come forward as very credible witness
whistleblowers and they testified before
Congress take a look let's take a look
back
in November of 2022 the statute of
limitations was set to expire for the
2014 and 2015 charges in DC which
included the 2014 felonies for the
attempt to evade or defeat tax and fraud
or false statement regarding berezma
income earned by Hunter Biden in those
years the statute of limitations have
been extended through a tolling
agreement with Hunter buys defense
counsel and they were willing to extend
it past November 2022
Weiss allowed those to expire
I don't claim to be privy to the United
States Attorney Weiss or attorney
general Garland's Communications but
United States Attorney Weiss told us
that he was not the deciding person that
he had requested and was denied special
Authority after D.C declined charges and
that if California declines you will
have to request special authorities
again I understood the gravity of those
admissions with her full responsibility
lies the United States Attorney Weiss or
attorney general Garland is for congress
the inspector generals and ultimately
the public to decide
so who lied to the whistleblowers about
the jurisdictional authority to charge
uh did Weiss and Garland tell the truth
or did Weiss tell the truth that the IRS
whistleblowers because he was telling
two different stories and why did the
IRS whistleblowers claim both of them
lied according to what Weiss
specifically told them and why did Weiss
let the statute of limitations run out
on many of the more serious felony
charges on Hunter why was Hunter not
interrogated why was the Biden family
also tipped off before a search that was
scheduled to take place why did wise
take five years to do practically
nothing before getting embarrassed in
that Delaware courtroom with his slap on
the wrist sweetheart deal that would
have prevented any and all
accountability on all of these issues as
it relates to Hunter and that would have
flowed over to Joe as well the house
oversight committee they knew was
discovering massive amounts of money and
show corporations and the number of
members of the Biden family being paid
tens and tens of millions of dollars
funneled into these show Corporation
accounts Comer's committee says there is
evidence that nine Biden family members
including grandchildren receive these
funds I'd like to know what did the
grandchildren do for China Russia
Ukraine Kazakhstan Romania what did
Hunter do for these countries to earn
all of that money and after all of this
why would Merrick Garland appoint Weiss
as a special prosecutor why because the
fix was it this is what we have been
telling you for a long time this is what
a politicized and a weaponized
Department of Justice looks like with
Hunter's plea deal dead in the water
Garland and Weiss well they would now be
able to use this new special counsel
investigation that will buy them time
that will stall all any future Hunter
trial that will they'll attempt let's
see if it works they will attempt to
block all and any Congressional
inquiries and let even more statute of
limitations run out but remember there
you're they're not protecting Hunter who
remember was an admitted crack addict at
the time while all these deals with tens
of millions of dollars were happening
this is the Joe Biden Protection Program
let me be clear on this Merrick Garland
didn't bring that up today but he should
have this is now not about Hunter this
is about the president of the United
States who is now running for reelection
and whose doj is going after Donald
Trump with a Vengeance it's not a
prosecution anymore it has now crossed
the line into never-ending persecution
and by the way they want to cross the
finish line in 2024 and not have this
issue come up until then and I'm sure
that Merrick Rollins pretty competent
that Mr Weiss will be able to accomplish
that and the allegations though are a
real problem real allegations about
bribery real allegations about money
laundering in the form of these bank
accounts or shell corporations as
documented in that 1023 form that
trusted FBI Source we know trusted by
the FBI because they paid the source
over the years hundreds of thousands of
dollars well that Source accused Joe and
Hunter of accepting uh what five million
dollars each from barisma 5 million they
didn't want to pay but the reason they
paid was for protection filtered through
these many shell corporations that the
head of barisma telling the FBI
informant it would take over a decade to
find out how they actually paid the
money and unravel all that
coincidentally enough Biden did Protect
barisma by getting that prosecutor by
leveraging one billion dollars to get
this guy fire third in six hours which
he accomplished for the company that was
begging Hunter to please we need D.C
help shortly after Barista Executives
demanded that Hunter set up that phone
call with Washington D.C that was on
December 4th of 2015 that phone call
happened and immediately thereafter Joe
Biden began the process of demonizing
the prosecutor that culminated in the
one billion dollars being leveraged now
the bidens are not exactly known for
being the smartest people Joe of course
boasted about his quid pro quo after
leaving office take a look for yourself
I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from
yatsenyuk that they would take action
against the state prosecutor and they
didn't so they said they had they're
walking out to press conference said no
I said I'm not going to or we're not
going to give you the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars I said
you're not getting the billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I looked I said I'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money oh son
got fired and they put in place someone
who was solid
a son of a bee they fired him in six
hours and guess what as a result well
let's see Ukraine Got the billion in
Long guarantees and Hunter continued to
get paid enriched the Biden family
enriched based on Joe's actions the very
thing the 1023 form accused Joe Biden of
add to all of this Comer's latest memo
with bank records showing a whopping 20
million dollars of money this is his
third Memo by the way from from Russia
Romania Ukraine China Kazakhstan we went
into great detail last night pouring
into the accounts of the Biden family
and Biden family members and Associates
we now have photographic evidence and
testimony from 2014 and 15 revealing
that then Vice President Joe Biden in
fact met with several of Hunter Biden's
foreign business partners either over
the phone or in person beautiful dinners
at Cafe Milano including a corrupt
individual from stand including the
former first lady of Moscow a Russian
oligarch who sent Hunter a whopping 3.5
million dollar wire for Consulting along
with an additional later 120 million
dollar plus investment in their real
estate fund and according to testimony
from Hunter's business partner Devin
Archer Archer pictured here with Joe and
and Hunter on a golf course also
testified Joe participated to his
knowledge in at least 20 of these phone
calls that he witnessed with Hunter's
foreign business partners now of course
as most of you know Biden was telling a
much different story on the campaign
Trail he swore over and over and over
again he never talked to Hunter his
brother or anybody for that matter that
he ever discussed the foreign business
deals at all never ever ever ever take a
look
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas many
families I have never discussed with my
son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period And what I will do is
the same thing we did in our
Administration there will be an absolute
wall between personal and private now
based on everything we know from Hard
Evidence Joe Biden lied flat out lied to
the American people during that campaign
and guess what those lies continued all
throughout his presidency up until oh
maybe about three weeks ago take a look
there's this testimony now where one of
your son's former business associates is
claiming that you were on speakerphone a
lot with them talking business is that
what whatever talk business in England
and I know you'd have a lousy question
well what do you it's why is that a
lousy question thank you because it's
not true I would love for you in your
thugs Chinese Shakedown text message
were you sitting there were you involved
were you no
everybody
[Music]
the only thing they can do is make up
things about my family it's not going to
go very far
keep in mind according to the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act quote payments or
gifts to third parties such as officials
family members as an indirect way of
corruptly influencing a foreign official
that would be illegal Joe Biden doesn't
have to be caught on tape pocketing a
big wad of cash he can still be guilty
of corruption if his family members were
taking that money in apparently nine
bidens got paid including grandkids what
do they do for that money what did
Hunter do for that money was Hunter even
capable of working during this
complicated time in his life of
addiction and let's not over complicate
the Biden business model at all not hard
to understand or is now some are calling
it The Biden brand Devon Archer told us
that Joe Biden and his powerful role in
our federal government is the brand it
was not Hunter the brand it was Joe the
brand again they definitely weren't
paying for Hunter even Hunter himself
self admitted all of this during an
interview with GMA he had no experience
and energy and he's doing energy deals
in Ukraine and China amazing amounts of
money for somebody with no experience at
all take a look hunter in his own words
what were your qualifications to be on
the board of barisma well I was vice
chairman of the board of Amtrak for five
years I was the chairman of the board of
the UN world food program I was a lawyer
for boys Schiller flexner one of the
most prestigious law firms in the world
you didn't have any extensive knowledge
about natural gas or Ukraine itself
though uh no but I think that I had as
much knowledge as anybody else that was
on the board if not more in the list you
gave me of the reasons why you're on
that board you did not list the fact
that you were the son of course yeah no
what role do you think that played I
think that it is impossible for me to be
on any of the boards that I just
mentioned without saying that I'm the
son of the Vice President of the United
States no oh I was on the board of
Amtrak and the UN food program and I'm a
lawyer and he experience in oil energy
gas or Ukraine or China no none at all
why do you think they paid you I don't
know maybe because of your father the
vice president probably wow hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else